there have been two sets of skeletal
remains found at lake mead within the
past week the first was discovered
inside a barrel at hemingway harbor the
second set was found over the weekend
about 10 miles across from the water
near calville bay
this is probably one of the most
positive
buzzes that have been around scuba
diving here locally in a long long time
the recent skeletal remains found at
lake mead is keeping this las vegas
scuba shop busy they say curiosity is
attracting customers looking to explore
the lake there's a big difference
between recreational diving and
underwater criminal investigations where
people who
you don't know what you don't know if
somebody was to use searches right
knowing how to properly use a compass
but exploring they say can be dangerous
if the person is not equipped correctly
and unfamiliar with the area because
lake mead has so much history underwater
lake mead parks and rec says safety is
key this wind event was was critical you
know i mean like you know over the
weekend you know we had instances of um
you know just visitors um you know
getting distressed and lost overturned
kayaks
um you know so
yeah
the hazards of the lake never go away
the investigation still underway to
identify the two bodies discovered at
hemingway harbor in colville bay metro
police say the most recent discovery
shows no signs of foul play the one
found inside this barrel however does
that victim is believed to have been
shot and murdered in the late 1970s the
visibility is probably the biggest
limiting factor but like i said with the
water level dropping the way it is
things are becoming more and more
accessible
well lake mead park and rec officials
tell us that as the busy season is
approaching safety is key so when you
are in the water
make sure that safety always of course
is on your mind and if you do happen to
find something don't remove it and call
instead call 9-1-1